Hello again, this is section four of Stop Fighting Cancer.
Again, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters, I hope you're getting something out of these sections.
I, again, apologize, some of this first up, a little bit dry before we really get into
some of my favorite things to do.
So as we're going through this, remember our pillars, first of all, what is the cause?
Back in, what are we going to do with that cause?
And understand, even if we remove the cause, let's go back to our example of helico-bacter
pylori.
Helico-bacter pylori is a, is a grim negative bacteria that we're all exposed to.
There's probably nobody on the face of the earth that isn't exposed to age pylori.
Maybe, maybe even on a monthly basis, that's how ubiquitous that bacteria is.
Now, most people, what is supposed to happen on everybody, on most people, if you have adequate
HCL production, and you're stomach, you'll never get H pylori.
Why are we talking about this?
Because it really is a very common cause of cancer.
It is the most common cause of stomach cancer, according to the World Health Organization,
worldwide.
It is a very common cause of a lot of different cancers, and we're using it as an example.
So if I have H pylori, it doesn't mean I'm going to have cancer absolutely not.
But like anything, if that substance, that particle, that bacteria, gets into the cell, it affects
that apoptonic, the normal program, death cycle of a cell, and doesn't allow that cell to die,
or it affects the replication cycle, or the DNA controlling that replication cycle, it
can cause rapid replication, and the definition of cancer is a cell that doesn't go through
apoptosis, normal program, cell death, and it then goes into a rapid replication cycle.
That's what cancer is.
So that's something falling from the sky, it's your own cells going rogue.
So that it's replicating cells that are doing that same thing.
So a cancer is your normal cells that are no longer normal, that are not dying, that are
in rapid replication, and all sorts of other things that are going on with that.
So, but that's the definition of cancer.
So if we get rid of the H pylori that initially caused the cancer, in our example, is that
going to cause my current cancer to go away, most likely not.
So that's what we talked about in the last section, we want to use nutraceuticals, whatever
we're going to use specifically for your cancer, and that's where it's standard ecological
procedures, right for me too.
Should I debulk the cancer with surgery, baby?
Should I use chemotherapy to help debulk the cancer?
That's a possibility too.
Should I use radiation?
All those things have possible negatives, pretty much everything does.
So that's things that you want to consider.
If I do surgery, is that a good thing?
Well, it can debulk the cancer, but surgery itself is going to cut open tissue in the way your
body heals tissue is by increasing production of healing chemicals.
So one of those healing chemicals is growth hormone.
Well, growth hormone, it's cancer cells that are still there and circulating to themselves
is like throwing gasoline on the fire.
So there's negatives to that, but there's ways that you can naturally combat that.
Should I do chemo?
Well, maybe.
Well, the possible negatives of chemo are that chemo is attracted to rapidly replicating
cell structures.
That's why chemo can be very good at killing cancer because that's what the definition of
cancer is, is a rapidly replicating cell structure.
Well, then chemo is good, right?
Well, yes, it is, but there's other rapidly replicating cell structures in our body, namely
our immune system.
Oh, that's not good.
We needed an immune system to help fight cancer.
Yes, we do.
So there's a negative of chemo.
Also, our immune system made purposes to kill forward invaders.
Well, circulating tumor cells that are not working like normal cells are seen as forward
invaders by your immune response.
Therefore, long before your cancer was ever diagnosed, that cancer was giving off circulating
tumor cells that are not yet rapidly replicating.
But they have the ability to go into a rapid replication phase and then that's called cancer.
But they're not cancer yet, but they are tumor cells.
They're not going through a poptosis.
They're circulating through your body.
You could think of them as circulated through your body, looking for a place to send up home
and raise a family.
That's called the tasticis.
What's keeping them at bay is your immune response.
So if I'm going to shut down my immune response with a chemotherapy, well, then I'm increasing
by risk of metastasis.
You are de-curry senior risk of more growth at that cancer site.
If it's still in a rapid replication phase, that's the benefit of chemotherapy.
But you're increasing your risk of metastasis.
So if you choose to do that, there's things that we want to do to really build our immune
response and to really help kill out those circulating tumor cells.
And I try to discourage you to do anything standard, but you want to couple it with some
things that will help you go through that.
Radiation is no different.
It has negatives and positives as well.
So we talk about all those things through this book.
While this section, we continue on from what we spoke about in the last section.
What is the publication bias out there?
The biggest step that I get from the medical profession always is where are your studies?
Where are your studies?
If your stuff worked, then there should be studies.
No, that's not how it works.
I'm sorry, welcome to the world.
Things don't get studied and used because they work.
Things get studied and used because somebody who's funding those studies can make money off
of it.
Let's be honest, nobody's ever going to make money off of alternative cancer therapy.
It's just not going to happen.
It's just not.
So do I have any hope?
Maybe I'm just a pessimistic, negative guy.
I don't know.
But I have very little hope that there's ever going to be great funded studies for what we
do.
There's just get used to it.
You know, I have surrendered myself to fighting against the flow and walking against the
current and know that there's going to be abuse and lots of negativity and maybe jail time
for me.
But it's just, I'd rather do what's right and good in the eyes of God and go through persecution
because of that.
Then to go with the flow and live a wonderful, comfortable life, it's just, it's just not worth
it.
There's, you keep your eyes focused on eternity at all times.
The last pillar, and what we look for, there's multiple other pillars, understand these
are our four major pillars.
What is the cause?
How are we going to get rid of the cause?
What are we going to do specifically for that cancer from a nutraceutical standpoint and
what frequencies are we going to use from a, from a right standpoint?
Now, if you've never heard anything about the right, go to our website.
I have a video on our website about the right, about a 20-minute video.
Give you a brief overview.
In this book, we're going to hit it hard and heavy too, but if you're, if you're anxious
to learn more about that, to go to our website.
But we use the right for every person that comes to us that has a diagnosis of cancer, they
go home with a right and sleep with it.
We'll get more into that in greater detail, but that's frequency medicine, how we can help
kill the cancer directly using light frequency.
And then there are multiple other causes that we're going to dig into some of those in this
book.
What diets are we going to use for that person?
We do specific metabolic testing on that, even though I give you, in this book, some sample
diet.
It's just understand I wrote this book for people who would never be able to come see me.
So there's a lot of my favorite things to come in.
There's a specific diet that you can follow, but in honesty, if we have a patient, we
need to test it out specifically.
You can eat this, you can eat this, you can eat this, you cannot eat this.
So it is, it is much more specific and not quite as rigid most of the time for people.
I hope you're enjoying this.
I'm trying to keep these videos short so that it'll keep your attention.
I will see you on the next slide, next presentation, if always, if you have questions, please give
our office a call.